vous avez l'intention d'organiser des
voyages de groupe pour que les femmes
françaises puissent aller se faire
avorter à l'étranger on est un peu loin
du du concept vous confondez avec ivg ou
c d e régis les enterrements de vie de
garçon et - dans le hall à plus de bébés
trois ans et plus dans le et on va faire
des bébés
je vais être clair avec vous pour 400
euros
vous allez vous la coller comme des
malades à budapest
qu'est-ce qui fait kiffer les gars
[Musique]
sarr poursuivre par des chiens
la seule chose qu'on vous demande
c'est d'avoir un passeport en cours de
validité allez c'est tout bon combien de
ventes aujourd'hui les gars 12 12 super
tu as fait combien de 3,3 vous allez été
viré du casse tête est comme de klaus
arbres de chez castel je me fais chier
moi je l'en peu plus corps on en est où
10 ans plus tard c'est koi no job c'est
de la merde attendre à me dire on va
monter une boîte qui organise des
internautes garçons en hongrie oui parce
qu'on n'est pas rentrée chez castel
exactement
[Musique]
touche pas à taper les gens
avant d'être [ __ ] elle a été pendant
deux ans un genre mossad roxy
c'est un policier la police
ok rien que vous n'êtes pas
[Musique]
à